you make the first move or do you lay
back in the cut and just hope maybe they
come to you I fall back because I try to
chase no man guys my message oh you
trick them no you can trick them
we'll see you gotta teach okay I'm not
gonna teach you how one I'm all
so taraji Erica and Tamela strategy play
hard-to-get I'll trust women who don't
get do this
meanwhile Tracey eldest and Josh well
let's just say the guys perspective is a
little different than the ladies I make
the first move
push your line excuse me you dropped
something and she looked down a
conversation come pick that pick up nice
I'm learning son the day yeah that's gay
you know you smooth you like butter
sauce smooth yeah my macaroni with the
cheese that's what happens when tequila
meets and desperation I've been married
for years and I still haven't made a
move yet
what about spending the night on the
first date yes or no no yes oh yeah oh
good nobody's time Hey that's so much
information so how long after you start
dating is it okay to introduce your
significant other to your friends and
your family who you kondeh well I
thought Sunday in 52 three days you know
might reduce its up on one
[Music]